avanzando bien presentó hoy seis de sus
oficiales más importantes lo hizo desde
delaware en wilmington y dijo que estos
seis oficiales están listos para
enfrentar al mundo y no retirarse de él
de estos seis que presentó hoy dos no
tendrán que ser aprobados por el senado
el resto si de hecho le cuento que
bailén tendrá en los próximos meses que
escoger cuatro mil funcionarios que él
decidirá desde su oficina de los cuales
mil doscientos tendrá que ser aprobado
por el senado que sería de mayoría
republicana hay que mencionar que pues
está pendiente la nueva el nombramiento
de yale lleven al departamento del
tesoro estos nombramientos y el de janet
lleva han hecho que los mercados
reaccionen de forma muy positiva el
índice industrial dow jones de hecho
subió por encima de los 30 mil puntos y
el s&p 500 y el nasdaq los otros índices
de wall street también cerraron con 1.5
al alza
punto 3 respectivamente se conocen
también resultados y reacciones
políticas muchos republicanos están pues
ya empezando a reaccionar y a reconocer
la victoria de joe biden cuando esta
tendencia de apoyo pues sigue creciendo
tanto obviamente en los mercados
financieros como a nivel político
cristóbal pensilvania ha sido el más
reciente estado en certificar los
resultados que otros estados tienen que
dar este paso y que sigue una vez que lo
hagan
sí y pensilvania confirma esto certifica
estos resultados ya pensilvania es el
estado donde nace yo bailé certifican
también los estados de minesota y de
nevada a favor de joe biden y carolina
del norte certifica los resultados a
favor de donald trump en total hay 15
estados que ya han certificado
resultados electorales faltan 35 más
estados por certificar los resultados
tendrán hasta el 8 de diciembre para
certificar y para pues llegar a algún
tipo de acuerdo legal teniendo en cuenta
las demandas que la campaña de donald
trump ha tratado de imponer en estas
elecciones hasta el 8 de diciembre
tienen los dos partidos para llegar a un
acuerdo porque el 14 de diciembre pues
ya es cuando los delegados electorales
depositan su voto y ahí ya se sabe
oficialmente quién es el presidente que
obviamente pues ya los estadounidenses
no votaron es el presidente elector yo
bailé